yeah you also get the guys that
complained that all my days she didn't
know what she was doing in bed and then
now he started cheating five years down
the line because she's so dead and also
no wait no wait no wait no i've heard a
guy say we actually weren't sexually
compatible that's the reason why because
he was probably too much of a freak most
girls can't have good sex seriously most
girls are not good at six how do you
know
[Laughter]
no honestly most girls just take wood
let's be real like but if it's your
partner would you not teach them and
would you not
would you like not like grow like as in
you're teaching her what you like she's
teaching you what she likes of course
it's contextual
um i don't think you can be the partner
and not expect her to like certain
things but that's what i'm saying
certain guys they're just overly freaky
because most men are very simple to
please you
but
but guys would prefer a girl they could
teach versus because if she's coming in
a freak he's like where did you learn
i have this discussion with my mo
cousins my brothers i feel like every
guy says listen have you read men up
from us women are from venus one of my
favorite books men are so simple well
what you not saying peace of mind when
they don't want to talk just leave them
he will come back when he's ready and i
feel like because we're so emotional and
erratic sometimes it's like you know how
many are quite logical when you call
your man of a problem we just want to
hear
is it is it is that the reality most
times we're not doing well because of
our nature we don't we try in our heads
we're like like me for example
i feel like i can be very peaceful i can
be very understanding
but there are times in the month where
i'm not it's i'm just not having it
because of my i don't know maybe i can
blame it on the hormones or or that day
is just not the day or i'm in my head
about something that he's done
as much as i want to be peaceful i might
not be peaceful that day and so i feel
like somebody wouldn't be your character
no i'm not i'm not i won't be peaceful
i'm not saying that it's it's good that
i'm like that i know that it can be a
problem but relationships are never
perfect i mean i could control that at
work right i can and the thing is i do
control it in my relationship as much as
i can there's no relationship that
doesn't have fights or arguments you
know what i mean so but
sometimes you go from zero to 100 and
you know you've as long as you
acknowledge you've done it and you're
able to apologize and accept
accountability and try and change that's
quite interesting though because like um
phil said you can eat for most women you
can stay quiet at work but at home
you're letting loose like why is that
i mean you have to communicate with
someone
why does your boss have more power than
you it depends on what you call it in
new some women are mad and it's shouting
and it's throwing plates
i mean we see it on social media we see
movies and stuff like you know some
women do throw things around and they
need jordans
smashing phones smashing cars we see
that yeah
but
a lot of women are not doing that and
also can i say something before you got
with that woman i'm gonna lie you should
have seen her in all her seasons when i
say seasons i mean how she's reacting to
like how she's talking when she don't
know that you're watching how she's
dealing with certain situations i
understand some women are tapped some
men are attacked but i also feel like if
you're getting with a woman you should
try and see her you won't always see it
though you you won't even i think i
agree but i feel like you can see
everyone in their seasons you just have
to
i think in modern generation a lot of us
lack self-awareness hundred percent yeah
so
and i think that is more um
more women like self-awareness for that
i'm gonna say that just because
of the situation we're talking about how
prevalent are they you don't really see
men going out there and doing mad stuff
like that you see women doing that more
so
speak on it if you disagree i agree with
you i mean it's shown it's shown and
that's what i was going to say it's
promoted to perpetuate to perpetuate it
further and to empower people who don't
have
the understanding so for me
it's not about me but being
self-reflective is a part of day-to-day
life as a partner to somebody else if
you can't reflect on your own behaviors
you shouldn't be on in a relationship
what do you mean by self-reflective what
actionable items is that so if for
example you have a disagreement with
your partner okay
you should be able to communicate how
how that came about what
because men they use less words yeah
they don't want to hear a whole load of
talking let's be honest they just want
to get straight to the point
what can i do to be a better partner to
you in this situation communicating that
to your partner because you're the
you're the second in command if you want
to say
your your man is a representation of you
and you are a representation of your man
when he's not around
and when he's around obviously
do you think that's what men want
well i don't know do you think they want
like constant communication or do you
think they want to shut up no no no no
no no what i will say i don't know what
men want but i will ask them i don't
assume anything i'm going to ask you
every man every man is different
what say for example what davonte
requires and what's your name so yeah
oh sorry phil phil what phil requires
maybe totally different spectrums you
know
phil's married to his wife she's got
maybe not i don't know but maybe she's
got
six attributes of maybe the ten
attributes he really loves and that is
good enough and he can work on that but
if you don't if you're not
self-reflective as a as a woman and a
man together
i think i think women don't have to be
self-aware though in today's society
because they're not happy
because of the accountability element so
yeah there is no impetus throughout your
life as you're growing older for you to
have to be self-reflective and
self-aware because especially if you're
attracted especially if you are
attractive most men give you everything
you want you can get there's no need
there's no need for you to have to think
okay how do i behave in this context of
that context that's your fault i think
that comes with maturity given example i
was talking to a girl and she's very
attractive and i told her most of the
girls around you are with you because
you're pretty and most of the guys that
chat to you just want to [ __ ] you but to
her she just thought this is all
everybody loves me everybody loves me so
at what point in her life does she
realize that she's being used and by the
time she's able to realize by when she's
mature she's already beat out by bear
man so where's her valley at that time
why do why do women always think they're
tense
do they
constantly
i do i do street interviews all the time
girls will say i'm a tan i'm a
tournament i've
maybe their friends have lied to them
yeah but i'm saying that but i don't
have men do that
i've never my life i've never i've never
i've never in my life had a man say i'm
a 10. you know when i'm honest i feel
like if my like if i don't look nice my
guy friend will say you don't look nice
like change that i get oh girl you look
so cute so i feel like men accept the
reality and they're not going to lie to
you you have to you might not you sorry
person x might be really
minus one however her girlfriends
because of mental health and like a lot
of things they might just be like you're
really beautiful right
that goes back to the point that women
don't face reality i feel like the women
who say that they're tense don't really
believe they are anyway
when you when you see how they behave
they don't behave like they believe
they're tense they're just saying it
because of what they can get but the
point is they can go out in society and
be delusional yeah and that's that's
normal for women
and women women are built out of every
single bad decision we make can i just
can i just say about the 10 business
most of the women that lie to their
friends and say their friend is a 10
know when she's a free
allah sorry
that happens because it allows those
women who also feel that they're a free
and a four yeah or maybe a five or a six
feel bolstered up in that group do you
understand feel like the beautiful
friend like oh yeah girl you look good
but when you go out like your friends
looking a bit tacky and you feel a bit
more attractive
that's a dynamic in in play so they're
more desirable to men it's indirect is
it insulting for a woman to be called
average
i think if it's reality if it's the
reality it's the react honestly if
you're average your personality might be
like out of this world but the reality
is to the human eye or to whoever's
telling you are average that's their
opinion i don't think there's any form
of preference you might be um like 10
out of 10 to me you might be 5 out of 10
someone else it's just and you can't but
that's a female like you're not a 10 out
of 10 to anyone if you're average
looking but you can't take what someone
else is saying if you are average you
know you're average go and work on
yourself or believe in your average and
not be there
but i'm saying most people are average
so like oftentimes if i tell a girl
she's average they they get defensive
they're mad because it has a negative
connotation but just tell them fix up
and use your brain
so what is this average what is a three
what's a ten let's say carry five that's
nice okay ken's perfect okay
what are the what are the things that
make people these rings
that's what i was talking about like
women's primary value to the world is
your looks that's the most like valuable
asset that you can see every year when
they show the most handsome man exactly
and i'll just be like he's all right i
don't think he's all that but
scientifically when you go out and ask
people yeah because you find because you
find 80 percent of man unattractive
that's why you think that no i think
that's not right it's just not my type i
know but that's right that's why like
that's why you could find the most
handsome man on the planet
no i'm sorry i'm so late let me fit you
you keep interrupting me
stop and you could find a guy in the top
five percent of of male handsome and you
still find him yeah he's all right
and like that's that's that's women
that's true women do we do let's be real
we do it no but i think someone's so
nice and she might do even when you see
someone with their boyfriend you'll be
like
i'll tell him he's nice no no no no you
see someone with their boyfriend so you
don't think the boyfriend's mind no i'm
saying if i think someone's nice i
believe no no if you don't think
someone's boyfriend is nice how do you
know it's not for me no it's the
reaction what's your reaction
at least he treats you nice
to answer your question i say eight to
ten means you can get a modeling
contract eight you're the prettiest girl
in a small town nine means you're going
to hollywood based on your looks alone
10 is damn near perfect seven i go off
of kevin samuels scale so i don't do
sevens because people are either models
or they're cute pretty five is normal
six is cute below that
okay
but yeah that's that's how so but a lot
like on tick tock the other day
um
i i got banned but before i got the end
i commented on a girl because she was
going off on my things and i just said
another average looking girl coping oh
man because she was
because she was mad because i was saying
men prefer younger women it's just true
it's not fun i don't enjoy that i'm
getting you know i'm 25 i'm gonna be 26
in november i don't enjoy that but it's
just true
and
if you're average looking at 30 you're
below average
but you know she
but like that's in it but do you see
everyone silent because that's an insult
but it shouldn't be it's not it wasn't
because the insult is
even but if i said average looking guy
no one would really yeah
i'm naturalizing a man once i agree with
you but yeah yeah
it's so crazy because it's like men want
maybe what's younger than them maybe
because
you're bendable you're movable it's that
you're teachable whereas when you're
older you're probably more stuck in your
ways and also you're probably prettier
because you're younger unless you just
don't look your age mm-hmm that
shouldn't be the case however
people do lie because
if if you walk around you believe you're
10 and you're like i'm a 10 i'm a 10.
people are gonna shut you down and say
no you're not but if you go around
saying i'm a two that would also try and
pump you up and say no you're not even a
two you're five and it's true most
people don't wanna be honest about what
they really think because they don't
wanna hurt feelings
but i think if women really got that
pushback there wouldn't be so many
claiming their times
true i don't think i think women but if
a man goes on social media and he says
i'm a town i'm a town town i swear to
god women will be the first ones even
even you this is the most handsome man
on the planet
for a magazine and yeah
let me finish
and your first comment isn't it he's all
right it's i'm no hate to you it's just
part of like women but my thing is we're
not all gonna think attractive is
attractive that's my point do you know
what i think it is as well some more for
women's i thought for me let me speak